my name is Rami Yusuf and I feel
I feel the inevitability of God coming
into our lives about being Conan
O'Brien's friend I feel like I've wanted
to meet you for such a long time this is
the only correct answer anyone's ever
given right yeah that is the correct
answer God made this happen he really
did I mean the way we like came in and
hugged you and I was like I'm such a fan
we haven't met and then we meet with
this hug I know you walked in the room I
went to shake your hand you said I've
got hand sanitizer so we ended up
hugging and then I refused to let go of
you
oh yeah and the hand sanitizer thing was
just for the hug right yeah I was like
let me have a wet hand so that we and
then I noticed she would sanitize your
back which was weird your back was all
it was it was wet and uh smelled of
alcohol yeah but I wanted to be clean
for you
this is New York City like I don't I
can't just show up dirty I love it I
love uh I was really excited because we
were planning this trip to New York and
I thought I'd be so great to get to talk
to you because I love what you do I'm a
big fan of your work and so it was just
a nice happening that you were able to
do this you're able to come in yeah it's
really exciting yeah it is it's exciting
for me
um and I never get excited it's just
I'm so medicated
I'm incapable
I'm just I'm in a lithium coma yeah I
wish people could feel what it's like
being in the room with you because yeah
I definitely feel that um it's like a
melatonin of sorts yeah that's uh why
they put me on late night television
just to get people to go to sleep
yeah it's the only way America could no
and uh you know the ratings always were
solid because people fell asleep in
front of the TV and couldn't change it
right so people were like your
consistency among viewers is incredible
yeah and then they looked into it and
they were like oh they've all passed out
in front of the TV first of all thank
you so much for doing this and I have so
many questions
um I'm just going to start with I love
your show I really do I love your show
and I love the combination of the the
humor is so sharp and and it's so well
written it's so beautifully cast oh
thank you I mean really everybody is so
solid on the show I mean they're it's an
incredible cast it's really crazy I mean
and then it's cool too because I think a
lot of the roles are written for
everyone who's there and I think there's
this thing with that I don't think
people understand with TV is that you
have very little time to rehearse like a
lot of times you're meeting people at
the table read or you're meeting people
the day of or whatever it is we have
this really cool thing with our cast
where so many of us have kind of known
each other from different parts of life
for many years and I think you could
feel it on screen I think that was
something immediately when we shot even
our pilot or the first season there was
this immediate chemistry and everyone
was like it's the writing is and it is
on a level I think but I also think
there's just this well we know each
other and there's this deep comfort so
so your friends on the show are people
you've known for a while the guys you
hang out with in the diner yeah yeah I
mean like Mo and and and Dave who plays
Ahmad in the diner we've all lived
together at different times uh Steve my
buddy you know muscular disk I've known
him since the third grade so that even
on a core level then may who plays my
sister we knew each other for years
laith who plays my uncle I knew him
since I was 18. so there's this like
deep history and and I didn't even go to
the network being like these are my
friends they just won in the audition
tapes but I knew while I was writing I
was like oh this is this will feel
really good with them okay so an obvious
first question and it's something that
when I watch the show and I'm fascinated
by is where does is that guy you
completely or is he a version of you I
mean I think like you know we and I'm
sure you relate to this but I I think a
lot of the time without the idea of
writing without the idea of Comedy I was
writing and making things since I was
really young and then I know the same
thing for you so it's like
I think a lot of this guy's like man if
I didn't have that outlet starting at 14
or 15 yeah there'd probably be this void
because I don't think there was anything
kind of in quote unquote real world or a
real career that I could have ever
imagined no I'm not fit to do anything
in the real world and I'm so impressed
and stunned when someone uh is building
something anywhere near me I'm amazed
and every now and then I'll meet someone
like a Nick Offerman who's funny and
creative but also oh I just made a canoe
oh dude out of mahogany that I
repurposed and I don't understand
because I have no function other than
acting like a fool that's the only thing
I know how to do no it's really wild
like I set up a Wi-Fi routing system in
the house and that was that was I was
like whoa I'm really handy like that was
the closest I could get I have to say
that sounds really impressive oh dude
it's plugging certain things in in the
right spot and you gotta route it and
that was the most I'd ever felt like I'd
use my ends as a man right and then it
kind of ends there yeah just stop there
and I would think back to like history
I'd be like what would I do in a
different era oh that's all I think
about is and I've always often thought
it's a field in Ireland
some really crappy boggy part of Ireland
and everyone is building a stone wall
and I'm in the corner doing bits yeah
yeah yeah and they're all like are they
[ __ ]
oh Jesus says he assistant shut up
doesn't [ __ ] shut up and you're so
tall and I'm not doing anything I'm not
I'm not or I'm doing a bit about like
putting you know I'm doing a bit with
the stones and and look at me I'm Stoney
stonerson and I'm gonna make a stone one
and you're like just [ __ ] build a
wall we got to get this Farm wall built
you [ __ ] ass and Jester was a thing
though yeah yeah but I'd have been
murdered very quickly I think I would
have been beaten by the townspeople you
know what I mean well I would I would I
think about this a lot and then yeah I I
would see murder for sure in my life uh
at that period I I feel like I would
maybe be like a food tester for the king
just to make sure that like kind of that
like is there poison in this hey Rami
come over here take a bite of this
here's what never made sense to me about
food food testers poison does take a
little while I never got that where
someone's like you taste this pudding
okay I tasted it I'm still alive very
good I'm going to eat great quantities
of this pudding
the guy dies four hours later the king
half an hour after that right that's how
it should work or maybe it's maybe it's
always been like a 15 minute kind of
like when they wait after the vaccine to
make sure you're doing maybe 15 minutes
has been like the universal it's like
now with Pfizer or whatever but it's
shown since then it's like we'll know in
15 minutes yeah nothing is everything is
15 minutes everything's 15 minutes
nothing's that slow release wow okay 15
minutes one pile eat the pudding this is
good to know
um but yeah so not much else I could
have done so but I think the character
on screen is very is kind of you know I
think I was trying to go to college for
a bit and and I think I I left pretty
quick I wasn't able to do it but it was
because I had something that I really
loved right and so I think the character
is without love and I think in a way
that that kind of hole that he has you
know we kind of all try to fill that
yeah people can fill it with a passion
with a relationship with God with with
whatever it might be and I think he's
kind of struggling with with what goes
in that in that kind of empty puzzle
piece in him the character is trying so
hard to find his relationship to his
religion God and is that you is is that
something that that's your struggle as
well yeah or your your journey in in a
different way probably I mean I think
that like for him
um you know the answer feels incredibly
elusive I think for me in my life I've
found you know ways that I relate I've
found teachers I really gravitate
towards I've found you know the the
meditative nature of of prayer all those
things have genuinely made my life
better but I think I like the idea of
conceiving this character by someone
that's caught in the industry of
religion caught in the cultural Wars of
religion caught and all those things
that make religion pretty shitty which
is kind of how it is right now and so I
think that there are totally you know
glitches where people kind of get a good
slice of it I think I kind of wanted to
show him really in the crosshairs of all
all the reasons why this doesn't work
right now yeah and it's it's it doesn't